the international trade is one of my
core areas we know that growing trade
with third world countries probably has
some effect in widening the the gap
between highly skilled and less skilled
workers in this country when you import
when you export airplanes and and import
shirts you're reducing the demand for
less skilled workers you're increasing
the demand for engineers the but the
estimates my own estimates of the size
of that effect which were fairly small
but they're also about 10 years out of
date
and there's really been a tremendous
shift not only an increase in the amount
of trade but a reorientation we used to
think that Japan was the big competitive
threat now of course it's China and
Japan is a country which is high-skill
high-wage really quite similar to us in
terms of an economic orientation China
is a huge economy but it's still very
poor one with low wages relatively low
skilled workforce at least initial
indications are we really need to mark
up those effects so I'm not it's I just
want to say look we for some reason this
this this whole field of trade and
inequality hasn't kept up with the surge
in trade with China and to a lesser
extent Mexico that's taken place over
the last day
you